and thank you so much for being on the
program uh this morning it's been a big
day in the G7 we've just been hearing
from when she's seen at the prime
minister at the same time Russia
claiming victory in Bahamut in Ukraine
what's your understanding of the
situation on the ground
unconscious that the president's Ukraine
is with the G7 at the moment and has
been there to continue that
International
resilience and also against the
oppression of Putin in invading Ukraine
which of course has had a devastating
impact on that country but The Economic
Consequences as well around the rest of
the world so I think it's right that the
UK committed to sending long-distance
missiles it's great news that President
Biden has agreed to be training the
pilots providing the airplanes so all
these things come together to show that
the world is United against Putin
um Rishi sax also said that China poses
the biggest challenge in his words of
our age to Global Security and
prosperity increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad how big a
problem is China
well I think China is now being one of
the largest economies in the world it's
uh that careful steps that we need to
take with them in terms of recognizing
this isn't about decoupling situation
but working closely with them but that's
also why we took decisions for example
to remove Huawei from our 5G Network a
conscious of the concerns about possible
Espionage and different ways that other
activities could happen that would
support the Chinese regime but I think
it's critical that we continue to make
sure we have our eyes wide open that's
why we opened our doors to people coming
from Hong Kong to have permanent
residency here in the UK when changes
were happening in in Hong Kong and it's
that sort of element where I think we
need to I say have tread a careful step
with them
um okay thank you um I'm Keen to talk
about some domestic issues now if I may
um is it true that the Home Secretary as
well at bravaman asked civil servants to
arrange a private speed awareness course
after she was caught speeding well I've
only read the newspapers like your good
self I haven't got any extra information
that not wear any further details on
that it's perfectly normal nowadays if
people are found speeding to be offered
points or
to go on a course of some kind so I say
I don't know the details that are
referred to in the newspaper but I think
uh I'm sorry I'm aware the home
secretary's just decided to take the
points pay the penalty and keep focused
on her main job of um uh security but
also tackling illegal migration do you
have the home secretary's phone number
do I have her phone number I probably do
somewhere uh why didn't you message them
well because I think it's a case of uh
there's some speculation in the
newspaper I'm not going to get into
individual details
um as far as I'm aware there's people
close to the message so whoever the the
Press but you know candidly this is just
a case of um something that happened I
guess over a year ago I don't quite know
the details I can only read what does
I'm only aware of what was in the
newspaper do you get why viewers might
find it a bit frustrating
that
businesses can come on and say look I
don't know the details I've got nothing
to say on this because I just don't know
when you know it's it's obvious that
we're going to ask about this question
right why haven't you read the
newspapers myself probably about 20
minutes ago so I'm just scanning through
what was uh what's on the first page of
two of them well indeed uh like it's a
kind of page 32 buried lead indeed
Sophie but as I say people every day get
off of the joys of taking points or
doing a course of course there's more
there about how it's perhaps having a
one-to-one
the issue isn't whether or not she does
the course no one would raise an eyebrow
if she was caught speeding and did a
course the issue is the allegation that
she asked civil servants to try and get
her a private speed awareness course I
mean that's clearly not in the room of
what civil servants are supposed to do
is it
well I think it's a case of uh reading
that um it was decided that civil
servants shouldn't get involved in that
that's quite this that's the details
that I just don't have Sophie and uh I
don't make it my business to go around
phoning people at uh 20 past seven in
the morning when I've just read a bit of
newspaper to look into this do you know
do you just don't think it's a big deal
if it's true then this is because you
seem to be quite relaxed about it it is
a big deal isn't it she's asking the
taxpayer-funded Civil Service to get
involved in her personal affairs I think
that
um what I've said is I've scanned the
newspapers myself this morning before
coming on the show I'm not in the
business of phoning people at about 20
past seven in the morning to try and get
chapter and verse from or even they
might have broken the ministerial code
uh I might be worth the message surely
well I mean you're making all sorts of
allegations there's different elements I
mean I'm just not aware of the details
uh Sophie and as I say at the same time
uh what i is clear is that she swella
now has those three points and a license
and she's getting on with the job about
out tackling particularly legal
migration but also the wide security
elements of our country I'm just
I'm not really making allegations
because I don't know what happened
that's why I'm trying to find out you
know her spokesperson saying she accepts
she was speeding last summer and regrets
doing so she took the three points and
paid the fine last year I mean that is
asking answering a completely different
question the question is did she ask
civil servants to get involved in what
many would see to be an abuse of power
well you've read the same things that
I've read in the newspaper as well this
morning I don't have any more details
than that and it's not for me to start
speculating about what did or didn't
happen
okay I I I I'm not really sure what to
say to be honest um okay that's that's
the position okay the timing of the
league or the story is also quite
interesting it's not going to be an easy
week for the Home Secretary with net
migration figures coming out expected to
have gone up significantly
um could net migration hit a
record-breaking 700 000.
well again I'm not going to speculate on
what's uh make the statistics maybe
coming I think there are two key points
that I'd like to make which are that
since leaving European Union we now
control through an Australian style
points-based system
um the criteria for people coming into
this country
um who don't already have the
opportunity to do so we've also opened
our doors to people from Hong Kong from
Ukraine in really difficult
circumstances so the point is the rules
are there if we decide that we want to
change the laws in the future but
overall the Prime Minister has been
clear he wants to reduce overall numbers
on legal migration but the main focus
right now is actually on tackling the
illegal immigration that's why he was in
Iceland last week at the Council of
Europe making the case about what we are
doing with our illegal migration bill
but also that New Deal working with
frontex the European Union's body to
make sure not only around the channel
but of course people coming into Europe
in the first place so you know new
partnership is been forged there which
is really good use in trying to stop
illegal migration overall I'm Keen to
stick to Illegal migration if I may
um let's just have a look at what the
current situation is because it really
has been going up at a rate of not
recently I mean you can see it here um
the absolute spike in net migration to
the UK at over 500 000 and as you say we
should see an access he wants to bring
that number down he thinks it's too high
so how are you going to do that
well I think uh one of the things as
I've indicated we've already seen a
significant number I think it's well
over a hundred thousand people coming
from Ukraine
um there's also tens of thousands of
people who've come from Hong Kong and
still have the opportunity how are you
going to bring that number down but in
terms of
um I think it's a will be a case that
the home office will have been analyzing
the different sources of what's been of
people who've come in you know we
deliberately have uh this focused on
skills we deliberately have this focused
on people wanting to come to this
country and fill key gaps that we need
help with now but also a significant
element this is also about our
world-leading universities and about how
people want to come and study here as
well so there's a combination of factors
and it really is for the home office to
analyze and suggest different ways on
how we might want to tackle that in the
future
um it is of course the home office but
your view matters as well right because
I think the whole point of this is it's
quite hard to get some of the stuff
through Capital because people have
different views on how far you should go
and trying to bring some of those
numbers down so there's some the
telegraph obviously brief this morning
that the Home Secretary wants to curb
student visas by reducing the two years
that people can stay after they graduate
do you think that would be a good idea
well um also being in cabinet means we
have Collective responsibility Sophie so
it's not about personal views it's about
taking that overall approach on what it
is the prime minister's set a clear
priority about stopping boats to stop
illegal migration
well I was about to say but he's also
made clear
um especially reinforcer over the
weekend about how we bring those numbers
down so how do you bring them that's
literally the question I'm asking how do
you bring those numbers down well I
think that the home office is working on
that sort of analysis right I mean like
can you see that's not really I mean
you're not really answering what I'm
trying to get like what how I understand
but I can't talk about policy that isn't
yet policy of government so uh at the
moment we've had to take it like take it
on word then that the numbers will come
down magically uh because the Prime
Minister said that I think um uh you
showed me numbers from last year I think
uh seeing that increase some of that can
be explained as I say by the number of
people coming from Hong Kong and Ukraine
also about different skills sure well
we'll have a look at that for policy uh
that isn't just frankly uh
um well not decided within government I
then can't go into speculation about
what it may or may not be let's have a
look at the breakdown uh shall we
because you're right there are different
elements of this the the
um blue line at the bottom there is Hong
Kong and Ukraine which as you say has
gone up
um but then of course the blue the
lighter blue line above that is people
in work and that orange line at the top
is is students so so as you can see that
is the breakdown let's talk about
something that is a bit more in your
remit then hopefully might be able to
get a bit more uh guidance on that
um work visas obviously as you can see
from the chart big part of net migration
and your department promised Farmers up
to 55 000 visas for fruit Pickers next
year the Home Secretary says there's no
good reason we can't train freak Pickers
at home so so where is that argument at
have you had some difficult
conversations with the Home Secretary
about it well the farming industry quite
regularly relied on people coming in
from other parts of the European Union
potentially uh further to do this sort
of work and since the we've left the
European Union millions of people have
gained EU settlement status but of
course we've had covered and quite a lot
of people who were in the UK went back
to their countries uh uh across the
Europe and haven't necessarily come back
so it was important to try and fill that
Gap that's why the seasonal agricultural
workers scheme was started first of all
it's quite a small number and we
listened to this sector and that's why
we have the 45
000 number this year with potential for
an extra ten thousand now at the food
and farm to Fork Summit last week we
gave the certainty for next year that
we'd have the same numbers available
because one of the things that farmers
have said to us is that they want to be
able to plan ahead and so it's a balance
between what's going on with Automation
and the investment in that but indeed I
want to when I was at DWP we all at
local job center we tried to put Farmers
together with people seeking work and so
there's a variety of ways that we want
to try and do that but in the short term
I think uh certainly uh having that
certainty for next year was very much
welcomed by farming industry I just want
to kind of zoom out for a minute because
you know for many people can I just
point out those numbers don't count
towards the migration because people are
here for six months so it's literally
seasonal worker and then people go home
no it's an important Point
um just to sort of zoom out for a minute
you know for many people the rising
numbers of net migration that the PM
says he wants to bring down is a sign
that the government is out of control
you haven't got control of these numbers
I think we do have the control because
we've set the rules and you've seen
there the biggest increase by far
comfortable then with with the with the
higher numbers well the biggest increase
so far has been the number of people
coming to study here
now our universities are very keen to
have people coming from around the world
we also see it as a great way to
potentially attract Talent if uh if it's
easier to go and study in the USA or
elsewhere at the same time while we have
I think it's uh four of the top 10
universities in the world by
International rankings it's critical
that we try and make sure that people
have access to that Excellence
um because some of these things are
about building relationships not only in
the short term but in the longer term
and Britain's always been an outward
looking country uh and uh but one of the
things is about as I say the increase
that particularly happen with students
but also with Ukraine and Hong Kong
another example that some people may say
is a government that's not in control of
sewage in your department dirty Rivers
dirty beaches 300 000 spill events in
England last year is The Situation
acceptable
well I don't think it's acceptable but
that's why the water companies are
already under a criminal investigation
and that investigation was initiated I
think it was last year there's also uh
investigations being done by the
economic Regulators so together the
environment agency and of what are got
that combining congregation are you
angry towards the water companies I have
to say I'm pretty fed up with the water
companies and we've seen an apology this
week uh which is the right thing for
them to have done I think what's
important is to make sure that we have a
plan and we set out a plan for water to
try and Tackle these issues and let's
just bear in mind people didn't know
about these things until it was just
over a decade ago it was a conservative
Minister Richard bennion who initiated
that we're going to start making sure
all these sites were monitored all of
that will be completed by the end of the
year and that information is publicly
available I guess um some people might
say look you've got a plan but is it
enough and water companies have to
improve storm overflows you know that
effectively allows them to discharge
this sewage into our waterways to avoid
them going to times but not until 2035 I
mean you can't wait 10 years to have a
swim well there's a combination and by
the way our bathing waters are cleaner
than ever before so in terms of we've
seen an increase it's not a great
situation you've said it's not
acceptable situation well what I've what
I'm saying to you though is the water is
cleaner than it was in 2010 so 93 of our
bathing waters are excellent or good
that's an increase from about 70 in
2010. that's taken ongoing investment uh
to make that happen but in terms of uh
things like the storm overflows we are
dealing with the Victorian Network this
is where you have also combined uh
sewers taking not only stuff coming out
of your homes but stuff out of rain
water uh up until the 60s that is the
sort of investment that needs to be
fixed as well as the storm overflows but
it's why I insisted that by the end of
next month every single storm action at
storm overflow has to have an action
plan on my desk and we will go through
that and what happens if it's not good
enough what we do we will go back and
make make sure uh through our different
Regulators that that gets fixed okay but
in terms of the 10 billion that was
announced last last week by water UK
that's welcome but I have to say it's
similar to what we were expecting as
part of our overall 56 billion pound
storm production overflow plan but these
things do take time we're right by the
Thames the Thames but it's it's Bill
payers isn't it not that not the
companies who are going to be paying
that money right well I was just going
to talk about the scale if we're we're
sat right by the Thames right here that
project uh started about a decade ago
it's still not finished it's a huge
investment but that will be completely
reduces it's bill pay us to be picking
up the town for this right well we've
had a record amounts of investment into
that is that yes or no it is yes two
different ways it's going to be a
combination of course penalties and
fines are paid for by the company not by
the bill payer but in terms of General
payments I think uh you're right to say
that a lot of this investment gets
repaid through by bills it has a small
amount of return but I think in the time
that uh labor was in power 97 to 2010
over 30 billion pounds was played out in
dividends uh in terms of the last decade
in a way what's happening and what's
going forward the dividends will be
significantly lower than what had
happened in the past should there be
difficult at all should there be making
uh profits and well one of the money at
a time when Bill payers the ones who are
having to pay for what the awful uh what
has happened before well one of the
things that off what does is to make
sure that any Investments are deemed to
be good value for money uh one of the
things uh that uh also this penalties
can end up with re reimbursements uh to
customers but I think it's critical to
say that we are getting to grips with a
situation that we have unveiled that
scourge of uh sewage and that's why our
plans I think will be effective in
getting these Solutions fixed now you're
announcing plans to strip out red tape
in the wine sector what's the idea
so we've been looking at a variety of
regulations uh from the European Union
at the moment things like wine they're
governed by 400 pages of regulations we
think a lot of that can be stripped away
and make sure that frankly this should
produce uh potentially up to 50 pence
off the cost of a bottle of wine so it's
about making sure we take advantage of
the fact that we can set the regulations
uh in the future get rid of the
bureaucracy and make sure not only our
thriving Vineyards at home we've got
about 800 of those now can really take
full advantage of the opportunities but
also reduce the red tape for some of the
wine coming in from abroad too so that's
a good way to toaster the forthcoming
summer and we'll get on with the
regulations as quickly as we can okay
thank you very much thank you